Good evening.
My name is Francis Ma,
and I'm a Product Manager
in the Developers product group.
There are many ingredients
in building a successful app.
And one of these is
having a great design.
Deign shapes your users'
experiences and motions
when using your app.
And having great design not only
helps them utilize and navigate
through your app, but
it also delights them,
and provides a great experience
across different platforms
and form factors.
Now, these were
some of the things
that we want as well from
our own apps from Google.
And so we've created
Material Design.
Material Design
is a design system
that governs interaction,
visual, and motion design
principles.
And that means it guides
how your app should look,
feel, move, and adapt
across different platforms,
providing a
consistent experience.
There are four principles to
building a Material Design app.
First is about
tangible services,
where your interaction
cues are based
on how physical objects
work in the real world.
Second is about
print like design,
where your content and
colors are bold, graphic,
and intentional.
[INAUDIBLE] refined to fit the
look and feel of your brand.
Third is about using
meaningful motion
to draw the user's
attention, and provide
a sense of continuity as
they move from one screen
to the next.
And fourth is about
an adaptive design
that can scale and
have a consistent look
and feel across
different form factors,
whether you're building
for a phone, a tablet,
or even for a TV.
And for your users,
that also means
that they don't have to
relearn your app as they
switch from devices.
And through these
four principles,
Material Design helps
you express your brand
through the use of these
bold and graphic colors.
It also helps you
delight your users
with motion and a
sense of consistency
across different platforms.
And most importantly, it helps
you increase user engagement
and drive growth, as we've
seen from many examples of apps
who've switched to
using Material Design.
Here is a before and
after of Snapdeal
after going through
Material Design.
And there are many
great examples
we've seen from
different developers that
have seen great success
by going Material Design.
For example, Trello is an app
that lets you organize things
by creating boards.
And by going Material
Design they've
seen an increase in user
interaction and engagement.
Another example is Pocket
Cast, a great podcast
app that has seen
an increase in sales
after going Material Design.
And those are just
some of the examples,
and we have many
more that we have
seen since the past
year and a half
introducing Material Design.
There are over
hundreds of thousands
of apps that have
updated their design.
And you can see some
of these great examples
at g.co/MaterialShowcase.
And in addition, we've
been working hard
to help you implement
Material Design with resources
available on design.google.com.
From there you'll find things
like the latest design specs.
An icon assets library that
you can just take and put them
in your app.
Also a devices tool that
provides the latest device
specs and metrics for things
like screen densities and sizes
for the most popular devices.
And for those of you who are
into interactive learning,
we have a Udacity course
on Material Design as well.
And of course, for all the
developers in the room,
most importantly is
implementing this in code.
And that's where we have
the Android Support Library,
with reusable UI components
that you can just drop in.
And with using the
support library,
it also means that
your app will work
on older versions of Android.
So be sure to check
out design.google.com
and learn more about
Material Design.
So going beyond
design, I also want
to share with you some of
the tools and services that
can help you develop your app,
grow and engage an audience,
and earn more money.
Let's start with develop.
These are tools and services to
help you build your app easier,
faster, and better.
Android Studio.
We've introduced Android Studio
2.0 just a few weeks ago.
And this is a massive
update from the version 1.0
that we made a year ago.
Specifically, we worked
really hard to improve
the speed and productivity
of using Android Studio.
We've taken your
feedback on this.
One of the notable
features is Instant Run.
Instant Run lets you
take code and deploy that
into a running app, whether
it's a connected physical device
on an emulator.
Here is an example of what
Instant Run looks like.
As you make changes, you
can see that reflected
in your running app
in just seconds.
So this is a great way to
really refine and iterate
your design UI, and to do that
in a very productive manner.
In addition to
having Instant Run
we've also worked hard
to improve the end
to end full build
and deploy cycle.
It used to take a minute.
Now it takes only 20 seconds.
And other great features
that we've been working on
is revamping our emulator.
Again, we've heard your
feedback on the emulator,
and we've been working hard
to make this much faster
than before.
With this new emulator,
it now runs faster
than most physical
Android devices.
And we've also improved
the UI to make it easier
for you to emulate things
like device locations,
or to do things like
device orientation,
and even emulating phone calls.
Another great addition
to Android Studio 2.0
is a new GPU profiler.
Now, for those of you
who are building graphics
intensive apps, like games,
performance is critical.
And oftentimes, debugging
your graphics code
is very time consuming.
And so with this new GPU
profiler and debugger,
it records your
entire GPU stream,
and lets you play
that back, saving you
countless hours of debugging.
It's a great thing to check out.
And since Android Studio was
built on top of IntelliJ,
their advancements
and enhancements
propels us even faster.
And with the latest
version of Android Studio,
we've updated to
the IntelliJ 15,
which was just released
several weeks ago as well.
And through this update
you'll see improvements
on usability and testing.
So there are lots of great
features with Android Studio
2.0 updates.
And for those rare developers
in this room who may be still
on our old deprecated
Eclipse tool,
now is a really good time
to check out Android Studio.
This is all available through
our Canary channel today.
In addition to
providing tools, we also
have cloud services to help
you build your app easier.
Firebase is a mobile
back-end as a service that
provides a real
time database that
lets you easily store
data, and also synchronizes
across devices in real time.
Also, it includes offline
handling automatically.
Another great
feature with Firebase
is user authentication, which
lets you integrate things
like Google sign-in, Facebook
login, or your own custom email
and password login,
so that you don't
have to reinvent the wheel
of creating your own user
authentication.
Another great feature is static
hosting, which is CDN backed
and SSL enabled static
hosting that lets you quickly
spin up a mobile web page, or
even surf your image assets.
Through Firebase Google
provides us infrastructure
so that you don't have to worry
about that, or the scaling,
and you can really
focus on building
differentiated
features for your app.
In addition to helping you
build easier and faster,
we also have tools to
help you build better.
And this is where Cloud
Test Lab comes in.
We know that over 44% of
bugs are discovered by users
after an app is launched,
and that 84% of users
would just abandon the
app after experiencing
an error for the second time.
So ensuring your app is of high
quality before it is released
is very important.
And with Cloud Test Lab, we help
you run automated and custom
tests through virtual
or physical devices
that are hosted in the
Google data centers.
We provide access to the
most popular Android devices,
and also let you run
these tests in parallel.
So you can test things in
different languages, device
orientations, or even in
different Android versions,
all in parallel.
And doing this is very easy.
All you have to do
is upload your APK.
And with our robo
tests that means,
even if you have not
written any test case,
we automatically
crawl through the app
and capture screenshots,
videos, and crash logs for you.
And we also worked
hard to integrate this
into your product-- into
your development workflow,
and made it accessible through
Google Play in Android Studio.
So when you publish an app
through the alpha or beta
channel of Google Play, we
will automatically run your APK
through the Cloud
Test Lab to help
you catch those errors
early, before it
gets broadly distributed.
This feature is now in beta,
and we're continuing our roll
out in the coming months.
So I've talked about some tools
that help you develop your app.
Let's switch gears
to talk about ways
to help you grow and
engage your audience.
For those of you who are
building for the mobile web,
we've heard your feedback
and the challenges you
face in re-engaging your users.
So we've been working
hard to extend the Chrome
platform to bring native like
capabilities to help you drive
re-engagement, with things
like push notifications even
if the browser is
closed, the ability
to add your app to the home
screen as if it was installed,
and let users quickly re-access
that from their home screen.
And also the ability to
work offline, and 2G support
with service workers.
Flipkart is a great
example of a company that
has taken advantage of
some of these capabilities
and created Flipkart Lite.
We're going to have another
session later on today
to go more in depth and
talk about these features.
So be sure to stay
tuned for that.
Another great example
of re-engagement
is using push notifications.
And this where Google
Cloud Messaging comes in.
Google Cloud Messaging
lets you send messages
from the cloud over
to your devices.
And we've seen
incredible traction
of developers using this.
Today there over
150 billion messages
that are processed each day
through Google Cloud Messaging.
And there are over
750,000 apps using it.
We're working really
hard to continue
to improve the
scalability of this
so that you don't have
to worry about managing
your own infrastructure.
And over the past months,
we've expanded the capabilities
of Google Cloud Messaging
to not only work on Android,
but also work on Chrome and iOS.
And we've introduced a feature
called Topic Messaging, which
lets you subscribe to multiple
devices to a specific topic
and send a message specifically
targeting to those devices.
For example, if you're
building a news app,
you can send a
notification only to users
that are interested in
sports and not in finance.
Google handles this fan out
for and the scaling for you
so you don't have to.
Using Google Cloud
Messaging is free.
And starting today
with Topic Messaging,
we've also made this unlimited.
Another great way to
drive re-engagement
is by making your content
available through Google
Search.
And this is where app
indexing comes in.
App indexing lets you index
your native app contents
and make that discoverable
through Google Search.
We see over $100 billion queries
per day in Google Search.
So this is a really
great way to get
in front of the users and drive
re-engagement of your app.
So in addition to
your organic campaigns
to drive re-engagement, another
great way to expand your reach
is by using Google AdWords.
With universal app campaigns
through Google AdWords,
we help you reach users
across Google Search, YouTube,
the Google Display
Network, and Google Play.
Setting this up is very easy.
You just have to create one
campaign, specify your budget,
the amount you want to
pay to drive and install.
And we would automatically
handle this for you
to reach the most relevant users
across all of these channels.
So I've talked about
some tools that
can help you develop your
app, services that can
help you grow your audience.
So now let's switch gears to
talk about earning more money.
Now, many of you are building
apps not just for fun.
And it's important to be
able to earn money and grow
a successful business.
One of these ways to do
that is by using display ads
through AdMob.
There are over 650,000 apps
integrated with AdMob today.
And we've seen
incredible traction here
from Indian developers
using AdMob,
with over 100,000
apps integrated.
We've been working hard to
make this platform smarter,
and the ability to provide a
more customized and tailored
experience for your users.
For example, for folks who
may have in-app purchases,
we help you figure out which
ones are likely buyers,
and be able to tailor the
experience to the buyers.
So an example of that is through
the in-app purchase house ads.
So when you offer
an in-app purchase,
some users may decide to buy,
and some of them may not.
AdMob would automatically
figure out which ones of these
are likely buyers, and
only show these buyers
your in-app purchase offers,
so that you can continue
to monetize and keep them
retained in your app,
while for the rest
of the users you can
monetize through display ads.
Another example of
AdMob is Mediation,
which means you can run ads
across multiple ad networks
through AdMob without
having to manage
the complexities of
these multiple networks
or having to integrate
multiple SDKs in your app.
And we also have ad network
optimization features,
which we would
check in real time,
from all of these ad networks,
which of those is the highest
paying, every ad request.
And we only then
show the highest
paying one in your app to help
you maximize your earnings.
We're also investing
heavily into providing
ad formats that provide
great experiences on mobile,
with things like native ads that
can be integrated into your app
experience, or lightbox
ads that are interactive,
or video ads where
users only need to watch
the videos if they choose to.
Beyond ads another
great way to monetize
is through in-app purchases.
Now, we've heard
feedback in wanting
to have more flexible
pricing options,
especially to tailor that for
more of the local user needs.
And so a few months ago
we've introduced the ability
to lower your price points on
Google Play and make your app,
or your in-app content
for as low as 10 rupees.
We've also been working hard
to expand additional payment
options, with prepaid
vouchers and gift cards.
These are available in
over 500 retail stores
across 22 cities in India.
And they're also available
on e-commerce sites
like Snapdeal and Amazon.
And they can also be purchased
with cash on delivery.
So we're super excited
about the opportunity
in working with all of you to
provide tools and products that
can help you develop great apps,
grow and engage your user base,
and to help you earn more money.
You can check out the
things that I've just talked
about at developers.google.com.
And now, I'd like
to introduce Kunal
to talk about [INAUDIBLE].
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.